Якщо не забезпечити "ковідного" хворого у важкому стані киснем,
в організмі відбудуться незворотні зміни, які у більшості випадків приводять до смерті.
Утім, саме з киснем в українських лікарнях наразі виникла велика проблема.
Про дефіцит кисню б'ють на сполох на Чернігівщині, Луганщині, у Запоріжжі, Херсоні
Одеська волонтерка Катерина Ножевникова повідомляє, що хворі на коронавірус
в Одесі теж задихаються в очікуванні кисню.
Та й у Харкові на тлі зростання кількості хворих, ситуація з киснем різко погіршується,
розповіла DW волонтерка Наталя Попова.
Ціна на кисень у перекупників підскочила вдвічі-втричі.
Постачальники, з якими поспілкувалася DW, кажуть,
що ледь встигають виконувати замовлення з лікарень, які потребують кисню все більше.
Київське підприємство "Кріогенсервіс" обслуговує близько 40 опорних лікарень по Україні.
Тут уже найняли на роботу додаткових водіїв і закуповують додаткові машини з цистернами.
Ми раніше починали роботу з 8-ої ранку -
нині так не виходить.
Треба о 5-тій приходити, о 6-тій. І вночі їдемо, коли поступають заявки.
Такого, щоб на 8 прийшов і нормально пішов додому - такого немає.
Кисневик 6-тої київської лікарні Петро Герун
ще з двома колегами теж працює за посиленим графіком.
Дуже велике споживання кисню. Бачите, хворих багато.
Постачальники, з якими спілкувалася DW, кажуть, що вимушені відмовляти лікарням,
які потребують більше кисню, ніж передбачають договори на закупівлю.
Ситуація, кажуть на підприємстві "Кріогенсервіс", доволі критична.
На сьогодні є близько 20 звернень від лікарень
з усієї України щодо збільшення обсягів постачання кисню.
Але ми не можемо їх забезпечити. Самого кисню вже не вистачає.
Доводиться додаткові запити давати до інших великих виробників,
за що ми отримуємо відмову.
В Україні є 16 компаній, які мають ліцензії на медичний кисень.
З них лише 5 виробників сировини - рідкого кисню.
Інші 11 здебільшого лише перетворюють
рідкий кисень у газоподібний і постачають лікарням.
Це медичний кисень, який, згідно з приписами,
має містити не менше 95,5% кисню.
Оскільки потужності цих фірм вже майже вичерпані,
допомогти могли б підприємства хімічної та металургійної галузі,
які виробляють так званий технічний кисень.
У ньому міститься 95,7% кисню, що теж відповідає медичним вимогам.
Однак тут нині затримка з оформленням ліцензій.
Кисень нині можна закуповувати лише в тих компаніях, які виробляють медичний кисень.
Але загалом є набагато більше компаній, які виробляють немедичний кисень
і які могли б задовольняти потреби лікарень.
Але, на жаль, у них немає відповідного ліцензування і дозволів,
щоб це робити і продавати це лікарням.
Чому зараз не можна отримувати цей дозвіл? Це дуже велике питання
до пана Степанова та інших інстанцій.
Тим часом міністр охорони здоров’я Максим Степанов категорично проти
використання технічного кисню в медицині. Вінв важає це неприпустимим "експериментом".
Наголошую: використання технічного кисню у лікарнях
не буде дозволено на території України.
Так само, як не дозволено у всіх цивілізованих країнах світу.
Бо це вибухонебезпечно і може коштувати життів.
Нагадаю, що через це вже відбулася трагедія -
у 2010 році у 7-й лікарні міста Луганськ,
де загинули люди через вибух балону з технічним киснем.
У благодійному фонді "Пацієнти України " вважають,
що нещасні випадки в лікарнях через кисень -
це питання дотримання правил безпеки та стану обладнання.
Фонд проаналізував, що щонайменше третина з 405 опорних лікарень,
які нині приймають "ковідних" пацієнтів,
мають застарілі системи постачання кисню.
Треба перевірити станції, наскільки вони робочі,
щоб там не було аварійних ситуацій.
Після того дозволити всім компаніям, хто може виробляти цей кисень,
постачати його в лікарні.
Це два елементарні кроки, які дозволять нехай не вирішити, але бодай поліпшити ситуацію.
Майже кожна опорна лікарня України має на сьогодні ті чи інші проблеми з киснем.
Встановлювати кисневі точки, кисневі траси, оперативно докуповувати кисень
зі збільшенням кількості пацієнтів вони - без проведення тендерних процедур - офіційно не можуть.
Я думаю, що треба на рівні Кабміну прийняти, по-перше, розпорядження,
щоб для "ковідних" хворих на кисень не треба було проводити якісь тендери,
бо це на місяць-два це все затягує.
Краще за якимись угодами швидко взяли, купили, поставили.
А по-друге, виділити кошти, щоб всі лікарні були забезпечені
Багато лікарень Києва не дуже добре забезпечені киснем.
Бо раніше стільки кисневих точок не треба було.
За даними фонду "Пацієнти України", чверть опорних лікарень України
взагалі не мають кисневих станцій і користуються балонами,
які треба постійно підносити до пацієнтів.
Або мають ось такі застарілі системи.
Тут стояла рампа до балонів і йшла в корпус зараз її зняли.
Саме в листопаді, прогнозують активісти, "кисневий колапс"
може сильно вдарити по лікарнях. І найбільше - по районних,
де нереально оперативно протягнути кисневі траси чи встановити великі ємності з киснем.